good to have you on this morning um look
uh
cred credit where credit is due it does
seem like the vaccination rollout here
in the united kingdom is is going pretty
well
just bring us up to date with the latest
thank you very much neil it is going
well we're vaccinating
on average 140 people that first jab
uh literally a minute that's the average
so some areas are doing
better you'll see that improve as we
open more of the large vaccination
centers
17 in total uh by this week
and of course 50 by the end of the month
it's a rapid rollout of the large
vaccination centers and of course
primary care networks who are doing
absolutely a
sterling job to make sure they get to
the
residence of care homes which are the
top category and those who look after
them
and of course the over 80s now today
in some areas where they've done the
majority of their over 80s
letters are going out to the over 70s
and those who are clinically
extremely vulnerable but i don't want
your viewers who may be over 80 and have
not had
a contact yet from their gp or from the
national vaccination center to worry
because we will make sure that they all
get that offer of a vaccine by the
middle of february
there's four top categories but the
number one obviously
is care homes we'll make sure that all
care homes are vaccinated by the end of
january
and then the over 80s absolutely
critical so i don't want them to worry
at all as we now obviously spread
further to the over 70s
just on that point and just forgive me
if i'm wrong you appear to suggest that
yes letters
for for some over 70s will go out today
but only in those areas where a majority
of over
over 80s have actually received the jab
in their arm not just
received a letter correct absolutely
right so
in parts of the country all over the
country there's been some amazing
primary care networks who've got to you
know 90
of their over 80s uh some have already
completed in darlington they've done all
their
um care homes and absolutely uh
brilliant uh effort there so the areas
that have
uh got the majority of the over 80s done
letters will be going out and contact
will be made by the gps
for their over 70s and those who are
clinically vulnerable
in other areas were putting more vaccine
and they were standing up more primary
care networks
uh to make sure that they're able to to
vaccinate the majority of their over 80s
and and finish their care homes and then
move to the over 70s as well
no of course it wasn't you that said it
yesterday was it was the foreign
secretary um
himself so you you may you may disagree
but he appeared to suggest that
the aim is that everyone has got that
vaccine
uh by september is that achievable i
mean in fact
could we do it any sooner than that it
is
achievable um we are uh moving rapidly
and the
nhs family uh including by the way
you know nurses dentists doctors
gps and of course the 80 000
volunteer vaccinators that have come
forward and the 200 000
volunteers from the public who've come
forward
and you know whether through the sun
newspaper or other
campaigns um are doing a tremendous job
so
we're confident we've got millions of
doses coming through
in the next few months uh of course more
of the oxford astrazeneca more of the
pfizer
biontic than moderna which has just been
approved
which will come through in the spring
and others we've got about 367 million
doses that the uk government has bought
for the four nations of the united
kingdom
um so in terms of the the rollout of
this vaccine of course as we mentioned
the
the 10 new mass vaccination centers
opening their doors today
when might we get to the 24-hour
rolling vaccination that we've had you
know people from the prime minister down
talking about
so we're going to pilot the 24-hour
vaccination
uh the nhs is going to pilot that in uh
hospitals in london
um and we'll look at how we expand that
but remember neil the important thing is
not just
you know once you go to 24 hours you
want to make sure you're targeting
uh really forensically really carefully
those who you want to protect the the
over 80s
have to be protected and the eight to
eight opening
actually works much more conveniently
for those who are uh over 80 and of
course
then as you move down the age groups it
becomes much more convenient for people
to go
late at night or in the early hours but
at the moment
the challenge is obviously supply
limited supply of vaccine
that needs to get into the arms of the
most vulnerable four
cohorts so that targeting has to be
really really precise
so that we can protect them by mid
february that's 88 percent of mortality
so you know if you just want to you know
chase volume
chase speed uh and not accuracy
um 24 hours works really well if you
want to chase both
accuracy protecting the most vulnerable
and of course
speed then you want to do what we're
doing which is primary care networks
hospitals large vaccination centers and
of course pharmacies last week
where we launched in six there's another
63 going live
uh this week in community and
independent pharmacies
and i pay great tribute to the pharmacy
sector as well for joining in this
battle
indeed indeed um but but just in terms
of that which you said about but london
hospitals being involved in this pilot
i understand no one wants to put a very
specific date on things but when
might we see that coming on perhaps
before the end of january
before the end of january absolutely we
will be we'll be piloting 24
7 um vaccination the nhs has done a
tremendous job and i'm
grateful for that for this compliment um
i
i i you know take uh no credit for it
i'm standing on the shoulders of heroes
uh which is the nhs family who are
delivering
this extraordinary uh coming together
the best of british
volunteers the vaccinators the doctors
nurses dentists
pharmacists all coming together to make
sure we protect
the most vulnerable cohorts as quickly
as possible
88 of the mortality is accounted for by
the top four categories that we hope
to make sure that they get the offer of
the vaccine by mid-february
of course then the the next very tricky
question becomes
who gets it after the the top four uh
cohorts i mean
are we considering for example something
we've talked about on the show a few
times
giving the police priority is there
potentially an argument for saying
you know people like yourself lawmakers
working in westminster
should be vaccinated as a priority
so we'll keep going down the next five
cohorts
there's nine cohorts that the joint
committee on vaccination and
unionization have given us as the
priority
based uh predominantly on age and of
course those are the most
vulnerable the uh clinically most
vulnerable to death from the virus
because ultimately this is a race
against death
once we get through those nine that's
phase one and we're doing that at speed
as you can see
we're publishing daily data then phase
two
we will obviously work with the joint
committee on vaccination immunization
but my very strong instinct and i've
said this to the select committee
is that those who through their work
through their profession
may come into contact uh
disproportionately
with the va with the virus police men
and women
shop workers teachers incredibly
important
because we want to make sure schools
reopen fully they're now
doing an amazing job teaching the
children of nhs
front line and of course other frontline
workers
and the vulnerable children but we want
them open as quickly as possible
the prime minister wants us to focus on
that so my very strong instinct would be
to say
those through through no fault of their
own other than
their own profession their work have to
come to contact
be much more or you know much more
likely to come into contact with the
virus
should be prioritized a couple of
questions away from your brief if we can
minister
opposition day debate uh on universal
credit today we understand
that the government benches have been
instructed to abstain what is the
current position on whether or not
that uplift in universal credit
is going to be reversed so the opposite
is in place for uh another few months
the chancellor has a budget on the third
of march and he will obviously look at
uh all the help we're putting in we put
280 billion pounds
of help to help the economy and of
course families cope
with this extraordinary tough time
of this pandemic it's unfortunate that
labour have chosen
a sort of political stunt you know this
this uh debate today
uh has no real um impact on the outcome
for those families other than
a political sort of little uh stunt for
labor i find it extraordinary i was
a few months ago neil speaking to the
civil servants who set up
the universal credit infrastructure the
biggest infrastructure program
and the delivery program for the most
vulnerable families
in the country and i want to learn from
them how they did that
and when you talk to them and they hear
labor saying they will dismantle it that
they will get rid of it
they they literally you know
put their heads and their hands in worry
about an opposition that is so reckless
that wants to dismantle universal credit
so this debate today really is
unfortunate labor should be
coming out and saying they will
absolutely back universal credit
it's been one of the unsung heroes of
this challenge
minister um you'll have noticed they
noted the arrest of alexey navalny the
russian political dissident
uh on his return to moscow i i wonder if
you will join
a number of other of our european
partners in condemning
the russian government for taking this
action
well the foreign secretary will say more
about this but
we are very worried about the well-being
and safety of alex
navalny and of course uh
we we have to make sure that the russian
government answers
why uh a a a poison
was used against alex and navalny uh
in uh russia the foreign secretary has
been uh
leading i think uh the world in terms of
uh one being robust on the magnitsky act
but also
on holding countries that violate so
flagrantly
human rights but you'll be hearing more
from the foreign secretary on this